this is kurt novina speaking for steve
watts mario striker's battle league may
be the most mechanically dense mario
sports game i've played the latest
mushroom kingdom spin on soccer looks to
take the sport seriously allowing you to
juggle passes tackle dodge and cancel
moves as the situation demands even
before factoring in its uniquely silly
mario twists that makes for a high
ceiling that could conceivably give the
game a long lifespan but its potential
is held back by the fact that there just
isn't all that much to do
[Music]
the mechanical complexity of the game is
explained back to back to back in a
dizzying set of tutorials rather than
ease you in with a few basic lessons and
then teach you some field skills and
then progressively ramp up throughout
practical games mario striker's battle
league asks you if you'd like to do the
tutorial and then delivers all of them
in a row just as you're getting a handle
on tackling and hyper shots you start
getting expert level lessons that teach
advanced techniques like cancelling a
charge shot the mechanics themselves are
complex so the hefty tutorials are
understandable but it can feel a little
overwhelming when it's all dropped in
your lap at once
once you enter in the game menu single
player opportunities to test out your
newfound soccer skills are sparse you
can take part in a quick match or you
can play in a series of four team double
elimination tournaments called cup
battles that's it there's no distinct
career mode progression ramp or even
alternate rule sets to mix things up
it's a remarkably anemic level of
options which makes the whole affair
feel slightly unfinished mario strikers
has a great foundation but there isn't
much to do or see inside of it the cups
are the bulk of the single player
content and the closest strikers has to
a career mode those walk you through a
series of ai opponents each specializing
in factors like speed passing or
technique finally culminating in a
championship cup that puts all the
skills together against strong
all-rounder teams the cups are the bulk
of the single-player content and the
closest strikers has to a career mode
those walk you through a series of ai
opponents each specializing in factors
like speed passing or technique finally
culminating in a championship cup that
puts all the skills together against
strong all-rounder teams it's a fine
enough way to practice your football
finesse and gather some coins but
playing a passing focused team didn't
feel significantly different than
playing a technique-focused team
[Applause]
as a result the process of playing
through a handful of ai teams starts to
feel samey rather quickly that said the
matches themselves provide some
enjoyable chaotic soccer action the
fields are relatively small compared to
a real life soccer match thanks in part
to the cartoonish oversized characters
who occupy it there's a real tension in
the split second decisions of where to
find your lane and take an opening your
ai control teammates and opponents
aren't particularly smart which cuts
both ways and while you can swap control
freely among any of your four players
toggling to the right one in the heat of
the action can be disorienting no matter
who you choose to be on your roster the
goalies on both sides are ai controlled
boom booms these perform their function
decently but it can feel frustrating to
have no control over blocking shots on
your own goal that also led me to
suspect that there was some shenanigans
at play when i was breezing through the
championship cup without a single loss
and then suddenly the game seemed to
decide that i needed to take at least
one l
my shots were blocked with pinpoint
accuracy and my own goalie was suddenly
useless though it mostly works within
the familiar framework of soccer battle
league takes one huge liberty with
traditional rules the hyper shot which
awards double points for a successful
goal if your team grabs a glowing orb
when it lowers onto the field any of
your players can perform a hyper shot
with a swing timer that determines how
hard or even impossible it will be to
block
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this adds an extra layer of tense action
to the play between defending extra hard
when your opponent has the hyper shot or
working to open your own chances to get
off of a hyper shot it also helps keep
games from running away because even if
you're down by two with 30 seconds
remaining you can always hope that a
hyper shot opportunity will come along
and help you tie it up that said there's
a reason the two point opportunities
don't exist in real soccer having rare
opportunities for such a huge game
swinging effect incentivized me to play
extra defensively essentially playing
keep away from my ai opponents until i
could take hypershots it was a valid
strategy within the construct of the
game mechanics but it felt like it was
working against the goals of the sport
itself the hypershots are also where the
game shows most of its personality each
character has their own hypershot
animation toad uses his enormous noggin
to header the ball underground while
donkey kong squeezes the ball into the
shape of a banana and gives it a hard
smack a personal favorite of mine belong
to peach who just charms the opposing
team so much that their goalie willingly
turns around and gently rolls the ball
into his own goal it's adorable
the flip side of this dose of
personality is that like the single
player tournaments they get repetitive
fast watching rosalina kick a ball so
hard it orbits around the moon is
objectively dope as hell but i can only
watch the same can animation so many
times before it loses some of its impact
with only 10 characters it doesn't take
long to have seen all of their hyper
shots and become tired of a few there
doesn't appear to be any option to turn
the animations off this being a mario
sports game of course there are also
items distributed randomly across the
fields from item boxes these can have a
significant impact on the game but they
functionally aren't all that different
from one another the mushroom gives you
a speed boost but the other items a bomb
green and red shells and a banana all
serve the same basic purpose as
projectiles the lack of differentiation
makes them blend together without
feeling as impactful as they could the
other major source of personality is the
gear system which is where battle league
gets its name gear has the look of
tactical battle armor from high-tech
glowing eyepieces to heavily shielded
chess pieces if you've ever wondered
what waluigi might look like if he was
in tron or gundam this is a real treat
functionally the gear adjusts your
player's stats so that you can make
tweaks along the margins you might like
luigi's base stats but want him to be a
little faster on the pitch so you can
buy a piece of gear to boost a speed
these stat changes come with symmetrical
trade-offs though so making these tiny
tweaks doesn't feel especially rewarding
for your money since the boosts are
barely noticeable these tweaks end up
feeling relatively minor and might be
best for high level competitive play
generally i found that if i wanted a
faster character i would just choose one
who is already faster thanks to their
base stats most of the coins come from
winning the single player cups which
award big windfalls of coins without too
much effort you'll also be awarded coins
during multiplayer matches but much more
slowly so it's clear that the
single-player cups are where you're
expected to gather funds for most of
your gear multiplayer though is the sole
source of an entire separate currency
used to customize your pitch
since every match starts with smashing
together the two fields beautifying the
field to your liking is a neat way to
show off your progress the multiplayer
mode also offers decent personalization
options outside of the pitch itself you
can create your own soccer club with a
team captain uniforms a simple prefab
logo and a name or join an existing club
as you compete in a club you'll help it
earn ranking for the season the
multiplayer match matches worked well
and offered a more competitive component
than the ai battles which eased but
didn't eliminate the repetitive feeling
of the cups this seems to be where mario
striker's aims to get its longevity mire
strikers battle league is a thin package
without very much variety in terms of
game modes and options but it is a more
technically complex game than many of
the mario sports titles which may give
it legs for dedicated players sports are
all about proving your skill in
head-to-head match-ups and that will
have to be enough because there isn't
much else to it
bye